hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today I'm
going to be talking about should you
have a plan B or just stick to your plan
a so came from a reader questions so
coming in from Chuck woody I hope i
pronounced up properly from Twitter and
you wrote in saying good morning
everyone want to find out if it's true
or not to have a plan B but only stick
with our original plan a so thanks for
the question a great one something a lot
of entrepreneurs face especially is it
getting your business started the thing
is it never works out as you think it's
going to work out things will always
change you know as great a business plan
is you're going to have the minute you
actually start running your business the
plan is going to change what I recommend
doing is having a vision so you want to
have a main vision you want to have a
goal for what you want to accomplish but
how you get there you got to be open to
it right so you know for me what I want
to do is help a billion entrepreneurs
it's one of my main goals instead of my
business and most of the way I do is for
my website but how that happens on a
daily basis changes so you don't want to
be too rigid in how you go about doing
things but you want to have a set goal
asset vision for what you want to
accomplish with your company things are
going to change opportunities are going
to come up you want to make sure that
the opportunities are related to what
you're doing one problem a lot of
entrepreneurs faces they get distracted
right it's easy to get distracted by
shiny objects new opportunities and
forget about what you are doing and one
problem that a lot of entrepreneurs go
through is they just jump on new
opportunities new opportunities new
opportunities and never see anything
through to completion and that's a major
challenge the big problem so if you want
to have success you got to focus on
something and see it through so have
that mean go we'll have that mean vision
of what you want to accomplish don't be
strict on how that has to get done you
know let let things happen let
opportunities come but make sure it's
still in line with your main goal of
what you want to accomplish so it's
great to have a plan a it's great to
have a plan B it's great to have a plan
cdef you know goes on be open to the
markets see what customers are telling
you as an example in my first software
company we created software that was a
biotech software it helped companies
plan research to try to find cures for
all sorts of different diseases and
ailments and we spent a lot of time
working on this feature that we thought
was really helped
and cool but nobody else actually did
our customers didn't care about it so we
spent all this time creating this
feature that they didn't want and if we
just talked to them and figured out what
they wanted we would have been able to
build a much better tool now luckily we
still had enough great features in there
to be able to sell and they'll make it
into a real business but by talking your
customers you'll find out different
things that you didn't plan on from the
beginning and they'll take you to new
opportunities it's so adding different
features in based on customer feedback
from them that was still in line with
our bull we still want to build
successful software company we still
wanted to help solve different ailments
and try to help cure diseases that was
our overall goal how exactly we did it
changes based on the feedback you get
from the market and so when you're
starting up it's important to have
applying it's important to make educated
assumptions a lot of them are guesses
but as you get into the market you start
talking to your customers you'll find
that things are going to change and you
want to be responsive and not be too
rigid so again have that main goal have
that big vision for what you want to
accomplish have your plan a and B and as
long as the opportunities that come to
you are still in line with your vision
and goal will help you accomplish it go
for it if it's off a completely
different tree and it will take you off
in a completely different direction then
you have to evaluate what you're really
trying to do as an entrepreneur so
hopefully that helps a great question
one that I know a lot of entrepreneurs
struggle with if you guys liked the
video please give it a thumbs up makes
one of the more these videos for you
guys and if you have a question or
comment about plan a plan B I'd love to
hear your thoughts I'd also love to hear
any problems your face with your
business so I can try to answer them if
you want to leave it in the comments
below I always read the comments I mean
a lot to me so please leave a comment if
you can and we'll see you on the next
episode
you